[Music]
later today a committee meets for the
first time to come up with a permanent
memorial for one october
and this would be separate from the
downtown healing garden which
sprouted after the tragedy however that
is where hector mejia is live for us
this morning with details on this plan
from clark county hector
hey there john good morning and for the
past three years we've seen the healing
garden blossom into this beautiful and
serene place that it is now
an effort is underway for another
memorial a permanent one honoring not
only the victims and survivors but also
the first responders
and heroes from that night the committee
includes a survivor
a person whose loved one was killed the
night of one october
and a first responder to the shooting
there's also an architect
artists and the head of the vegas strong
resiliency center
the memorial is separate from the
downtown healing garden and it's
expected to be interactive and tell the
story of the victims and survivors as
well as how the community came together
the hope is to create a place that not
only documents las vegas darkest night
but also pays tribute to the courage we
saw in the community
the community came together and you saw
who we really
are when this horrific tragedy happened
i don't think anyone realized how strong
and how connected lost you know the las
vegas community was until this tragedy
happened
they're at a clean slate right now and
have a long way to go the process could
take
around two years before the site gets
built
now who will pay for the memorial where
it would go and what it will actually
look like well those details are still
being worked out and that's the reason
why
they're asking for input from the
community if you'd like to weigh in
the meeting gets underway at nine
o'clock this morning inside the clark
county government center
reporting live from the las vegas
healing garden hector mejia
8 news now